so let's return now to our top story
here this morning the 15th and 20th of
December are the dates that members of
the Royal College of Nursing will walk
out over pay the biggest strike in NHS
history so let's speak to a member of
the Union's executive I'm joined Now by
The Royal College of nursing's director
for England Patricia Marquis very good
morning to you Patricia Marquez thanks
so much for talking to us so the first
ever National walkout by your union a
big decision why have you taken it
well our members are sending a very loud
message to the government that things
need to change for nurses in their NHS
so we got a pay award this year of 1400
pounds which may sound a lot to people
but actually nursing pay has fallen
behind over the last 10 years by around
the rate of inflation plus five percent
so our members are hugely disappointed
that they didn't get anywhere near what
they needed to take their salaries back
to the level they were 10 years ago and
what's really worrying them is the
impact that that's having on patient
care there aren't enough nurses and
nursing staff to deliver the care that's
needed so patients are waiting too long
for their operations they're waiting for
ambulances they're waiting for beds and
it just is not safe for patients any
longer and nurses are saying we've had
enough we can't continue something needs
to change
and yet the health secretary for England
uh Steve Barkley would say that what
you're asking for effectively 19.2
percent of a pay rise costing 10 billion
pounds a year just simply isn't
affordable it's not realistic is it
so we we think it is realistic in terms
of the country needs to have more
nursing staff to be able to deliver the
services that the public need
so it's a choice that the government
needs to make but what we need to do now
is get back around the table and that's
the disappointment for us our members
sent this message a good few weeks ago
now to the health ministers and health
secretary and yet he's refused to talk
to us about the things that matter to
our members pay and patient safety and
really we can't we won't be able to move
this forward unless we do have
negotiations so we ask him again to come
back to the table to have some serious
negotiations about the things that need
to change to increase the number of
nurses in the workforce and increase the
amount and safety of care that people
can deliver
so if the health secretary Steve Barkley
has yet to meaningfully engage with you
over these negotiations what makes you
think that strike action will change
that
well I think we've tried talking and
talking and talking over years but the
government just hasn't listened and so
our members are telling us very loudly
now we can't just continue trying to
write letters and have conversations and
and they've they've given up that that's
going to work and we gave another few
weeks chance to see if things would
change with the signal of strikes with
the resounding message that the members
sent when they voted but that hasn't yet
worked and so it's with a really heavy
heart that we have had to now announce
dates in December when our members will
go on strike across the UK
well yes and how worried are you about
the impact on patients could people be
put in danger because of these strikes
well we found that patients are being
put in danger every single day and
actually when we take strike action we
will ensure that safety is is as it is
now so that patients are safe that there
is access to Emergency Services to make
sure that people
um you know life and limb services are
maintained but of course the strike is
going to be disruptive and we
acknowledge that but there is no point
in a striking unless it disrupts but
that disruption has got to send a strong
message to the government that they need
to talk and that we mean business and
that members mean business but we will
do it safely
well yes and talking of that disruption
this comes as there are seven million
people in England waiting for treatment
that's a record high this is only going
to make matters worse isn't it
I think we have to face the facts that a
day or two of strike action really is
not the issue the issue is years and
years of underfunding these waiting
lists have not grown to this level as a
result of nurses taking strike action
they've grown to this level in part
because of covid but largely over the
last 10 years with the underfunding the
reduction in the number of staff that
there are to deliver Services resulting
in increasing waiting lists increasing
waiting times
etc etc so no our strikes are not going
to make much difference to that the
problem is years of underfunding and the
action needs to happen now to improve
that
so what's your message to the patients
whose surgeries or treatments are going
to be canceled because of this strike
we're doing this for you this is about
nurses standing up for themselves but
also critically for patients
we know that the public support nursing
staff in general and we know they
support us through this action so we
want you to come on this journey with us
we are sorry for any disruption that's
caused but actually unless we do this we
don't see any Prospect of things
changing anytime soon
just a couple of questions on the the
process why did you choose to
regionalize the voting process was that
because you knew you didn't have the
numbers for a national vote
we think that members should have a
choice at local level and that's what
members have done they've taken that
choice at local level we also operate in
four countries across the UK and all
have different Health Systems and
different devolved responsibilities so
we decided to do that because of those
reasons and and as has been shown there
is stronger feeling in some areas than
others but even in the areas that didn't
get over the 50 levels set by the
government the numbers were huge in the
40 48 49 so we were very close and
members have spoken loudly across the
country even if they're not in a
position to take strike action they're
still sending that strong message where
people voted most times it was 80 90
percent of them voting yes to strike
and your strike one of one of the days
that you've named the 15th of December
comes in the same week as postal strikes
and Railway strikes has there been any
coordination with other unions over the
timing of your walkout
no there hasn't
um and in fact it may not look the same
if we were coordinating the reality is
that workers across the country are
sending a message to the government to
say that things that you know the salary
Rises that are being paid and the
threats to jobs in other sectors not for
us but in other sectors are really
having an impact so no there's not been
any coordination we are working as the
Royal College of Nursing on our own at
the moment
um and obviously other NHS unions sorry
Health unions are also currently
balloting their members so they may also
after Christmas be considering strike
action themselves
well Patricia Marquis a director for
England of the RCN thanks very much
indeed for talking to us here this
morning we appreciate it thank you